hi i'm priyanka vergaria and this is ai
simplified where we learn to make
our data useful in this video we're
going to imagine
a company that has large amount of data
which they want to use to make
meaningful predictions and take their
business to the next
level and we also know that their team
has
varying levels of machine learning
expertise to accelerate this ai
innovation
they are looking at vertex ai which
provides
tools for every step of the machine
learning workflow
from managing data sets to different
ways of training the model
evaluating deploying and making
predictions
in this episode let's see the first step
of the machine learning life cycle which
is the data sets
you don't need to worry about data sets
if your use case is generic enough
you can just take advantage of the
pre-trained machine learning apis and to
learn more about them
i've included a link below in order to
create custom
machine learning models we must first
have a collection of data to train our
models with
that is what data sets are for data sets
make data discoverable from a central
place
they provide the ability to annotate and
label the data
right from within the ui you can track
the lineage for data governance and can
compare model metrics between
the models now to create a data set we
first
select our data and upload it import it
into
the managed data sets and then we can
make modifications
and use it to start training the model
currently there are four supported data
types
image tabular text and videos
now image data sets currently support
image
classification which is where models
predict
one or many labels from an image now for
example
identifying the types of dog treats from
images of
treats object detection is where the
model draws
bounding boxes around the items of the
image
for example you're identifying the
location of different vegetables
within a picture of salad image
segmentation
is where the model can assign a label to
pixel level regions in an image to
ensure your model performs well in
production
and there's no training serving skew
make sure the training images are
close to the input your users will send
to your deployed model
for example if your images are going to
be low resolution
be sure to have blurry images low
resolution images in
there include multiple angles
backgrounds and all sorts of resolutions
it's recommended that you include at
least 1000
images per label but you can also always
get started with
10 per label the more examples you
provide the better your model will be
now tabular data sets currently support
regression where you predict a numerical
value
and classification where you predict a
category associated with a particular
example
forecasting is where the model predicts
likelihood of certain events or demands
for example you want to predict sales
over a period of time
now tabular data sets support hundreds
of columns and millions of rows
text data sets currently support
classification
which is where you assign one or more
labels to
an entire document in a customer support
example
an email could include classifications
as
great service or a suggestion now
entity extraction is where the model
identifies custom text entities within a
document for example maybe you want to
identify
all the phrases in a customer support
email that reference
pricing too expensive or great value
sentiment analysis is to understand the
overall
sentiment expressed in a block of text
for example
if a customer was happy or upset or
frustrated now video data sets currently
support
classification which provides label
predictions for an entire video
shots and frames for example in a
football game
you would be able to label the section
with commercials
and the section with the game now action
recognition
is where the model identifies clips in
the video
where specific actions occur for example
in a puppy football game
the action of a dog making a touchdown
now object tracking is where you get
labels
bounding boxes and timestamps for
objects you want to track in a video
for example in the same game you want to
track the football's motion
throughout the video now we just covered
the basic functionality here
i have included the link below for more
details and best practices
on data preparation at this point i
think we want to see how to create and
manage the data sets
in the console so let's dive in in the
console we get to vertex ai and click on
the data set where we see
image tabular text and video data sets
for the different objectives we talked
about earlier
let's try to create an image data set
say we want to do image classification
before we begin
it's good to check the data guide that
shows us the requirements and
recommendations
you can import files directly from your
computer
and they would be stored in cloud
storage we can then add the
corresponding labels for our images in
the next step
if you already have labels use the
import file option to import a csv
with your image urls and their labels
the entries in the csv would look
something like this if your data is not
labeled
and you would like human help to label
it then you could use the data labeling
service
let's upload a few files here once the
files
are uploaded we can create labels and
assign them to the images
we can also analyze the images we have
in the data set
number of images per label and a few
other properties
depending on the type of data your
options might vary slightly
for example if we look at tabular data
you could upload a csv file from your
computer
from cloud storage or select a table
from bigquery directly
once you select the table the data is
available for analysis
we can see the number of rows columns
etc
you would do the same for a text data
set once uploaded
we can see the labels or add new labels
to the data
and we can also analyze our data set
the video data set interface looks
similar i have some labeled sports files
here
for golf cartwheel horse riding
and others that was a high level
overview of how you can manage
different data sets in vertex ai in the
next video
we will look at the next steps of
machine learning workflow to build
and train ml models in the meantime
let's continue our discussion in the
comments below
i am excited to hear all about your ml
use case
and your data sets
you